[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 16 avril bienvenue dans
cette nouvelle édition spéciale sur tv
78 consacrée à la crise sanitaire du
coronavirus
comme chaque soir déjà le point sur la
propagation du colis de 19 dans le
département les décès continue
d'augmenter dans les hôpitaux 306
personnes sont mortes du virus dans les
établissements yvelinois depuis le début
de la pandémie est mais d'après les
données de santé publique france paru
hier le nombre d'hospitalisations a
baissé pour le deuxième jour consécutif
1025 personnes étaient hospitalisées
hier dans le département
175 placé en réanimation un chiffre qui
baisse également et un dernier chiffre à
vous donner 885 c'est le nombre de
retour à domicile suite à une
amélioration de l'état de santé
parmi les victimes dans le département
olivier du grand con pied volontaire de
58 ans décédé la semaine dernière du
coronavirus il était hospitalisé depuis
un mois à l'hôpital percy de clamart
dans les hauts-de-seine
un hommage a eu lieu samedi dernier à la
caserne de saint germain en laye et puis
plusieurs cagnotte en ligne ont été
également lancée pour venir en aide
alors son épouse et à ses enfants
le lien de l'une de ces cagnottes
s'affiche actuellement au bas de l'écran
la zone c est actuellement en vacances
scolaires et même pendant cette période
de confinement les services de
l'éducation nationale à travail en vue
de la rentrée afin d'assurer la
continuité pédagogique est d'autant
qu'un objectif a été est désormais fixé
par le président de la république
rouvrir progressivement les écoles à
partir du lundi 11 mai bonsoir charline
avesnelles bonsoir monsieur vous êtes la
rectrice de l'académie de versailles
merci d'être avec nous une question déjà
sur ce sujet ce qu'on connaît les
modalités de cette reprise dans
l'académie de versailles ou est ce
encore trop tôt pour pour les fixer le
président de la république et le
ministre de l'éducation nationale se
sont exprimés il s'agit d'un retour qui
sera progressif et donc l'ensemble des
conditions qui devront être mises en
place que ce soit la temporalité que ce
soient les modalités que ce soient les
modalités sanitaires les modalités
d'accompagnement pédagogique et bien
tout cela est en cours de préparation et
est en discussion il y à une
consultation qui vient de s'ouvrir hier
auprès du ministre avec les principaux
partenaires les familles les lycées à
les organisations syndicales et donc
réponses à toutes vos questions à toutes
celles que les parents se posent dans
quinze jours le délai de quinze jours et
qui a été effectivement fixé par le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer on aura l'occasion d'en
savoir plus d'ici quelques jours donc
pendant ces vacances scolaires un peu
spécial un peu le dire en cette de
confinement des stages de soutien
scolaire ont été mises en place au sein
de l'académie de versailles
ils ont débuté depuis mardi comment
comment cela s'est organisée j'en
appelle alors absolument nous avons mis
en place des stages de soutien scolaire
d'abord je veux je veux commencer à dire
que les vacances sont les vacances donc
nos personnels avaient besoin d'être en
vacances nos élèves aussi est donc
vraiment l'idée là c'est d'être en
vacances même si nous le sommes tous
nous sommes confinés
mais le confinement amène également de
déséquilibre des inéquité qui
malheureusement se creuse en dépit
d'efforts qui sont colossaux faits par
nos enseignants pour rester en contact
avec les élèves qui sont les plus
fragiles
et puis animé
leur leurs pratiques pédagogiques et
donc nous avons souhaité pendant cette
deuxième semaine de vacances apporter à
ces élèves qui sont donc les plus
fragiles les plus en difficulté 6h02 de
renforcement avec des enseignants qui
sont des enseignants volontaires qui se
font sur des thématiques qui sont très
très central comme le français les
mathématiques pour les plus pour les
plus jeunes par exemple et sur la bosse
base du volontariat pour les enseignants
de manière très personnalisés les jeunes
sont dans des groupes qui ne dépasse pas
plus de 6 de plus de 6 élèves dans les
yvelines
puisque ces départements qui vous
intéressent tout particulièrement
on a cette semaine un peu plus de dix
mille élèves qui sont qui sont ainsi
mobilisés et donc pour voilà pour ces
stages de soutien scolaire
parlons pour terminer de la continuité
pédagogique c'était la promesse affichée
par l'éducation nationale au début de
cette période de confinement l'assuré
perdurer un set cette continuité
certains avaient émis justement des
réserves en raison de la fracture
numérique
la difficulté pour certains élèves
d'accéder à des cours en ligne quel
bilan vous faites vous sur sur cette
première moitié en tout cas de la
continuité pédagogique qui a été mise en
place et bien le bilan il est positif
parce que en quelques jours
l'ensemble de notre communauté s'est
mise à faire l'école tout à fait
autrement par exemple dans le premier
degré c'est-à-dire les écoles primaires
on a créé en l'espace de deux jours
l'équivalent de 1700 blog pour que les
enseignants puissent mettre leurs
supports les ateliers de lecture déroule
le programme d'une journée les petits
exercices que les élèves font donc
vraiment il ya eu un virage colossal qui
a été pris très vite
évidemment on a été confronté au sujet
de la fracture numérique et donc nous
avons redéployé avec l'aide des
collectivités locales des tablettes des
ordinateurs vis-à-vis des publics qui
n'en avaient pas aujourd'hui se met en
place de 10
positive de la poste qui acheminent
encore aujourd'hui du matériel
pédagogique vers les élèves au total
on a redistribué plus de 3000 outils et
on ne va pas s'arrêter là puisque les
fois on va se poursuivre et notamment
maintenant que le dispositif de la poste
est mise en place
enfin évidemment ça ne suffit pas à
couvrir l'ensemble des besoins et
surtout à rester vraiment bien accroché
avec les élèves ce que nous faisons ce
que les enseignants font ce que les
surveillants font et bien c'est être au
téléphone avec avec les élèves les
appeler une deux fois par semaine
vraiment garder ce contact si essentiel
dans un lien vraiment très personnalisé
pour s'assurer que nous restons avec un
niveau d'accrochage de contact suffisant
avec les ennemis et donc cette
continuité pédagogique qui va durer avec
la rentrée rentrée en tout cas en
confinement 1 qui se déroulera à partir
de lundi merci d'avoir été avec nous
charline avesnelles merci monsieur et je
remercie et je rappelle que vous êtes
la rectrice de l'académie de versailles
31e jours de confinement en france et
dans les yvelines les mesures de
déplacement sont allégées dans le
département la pratique sportive est de
nouveau autorisée entre 10h et 19h
depuis aujourd'hui
une sortie qui doit se faire seul muni
d'une attestation toujours les limites
d'une heure maximum et dans un rayon
d'un kilomètre autour du domicile
l'activité est à faire bien sûr dans le
strict respect des gestes barrières pour
rappel le 8 avril dernier le préfet des
yvelines avait pris un arrêté
interdisant la pratique sportive entre
10h et 19h face au non respect des
mesures de confinement sur le territoire
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire un
salarié sur cinq est passé au
télétravail avec parfois des rendez-vous
en visioconférence une start up basée à
saint quentin en yvelines est allé plus
loin les collaborateurs confiné se
retrouve désormais en réunion en réalité
virtuelle un procédé innovant dont nous
parle nicolas landry premier format en
plus ou moins immersif numérique
c'est une méthode innovante de travail
collaboratif en pleine période de
confinement des réunions d'entreprises
en réalité virtuelle spécialisée sur
cette technologie
la start-up minimes antenne sky one
porte à la mise en place cette nouvelle
organisation
on a des contenus qu'on s'est fait
rendre réseau conseille d'utiliser vos
casques et même sur pc on s'est dit
allez on va essayer en quelques jours
finalement on a repris notre base de
code et on a intégré une sorte d'outil
qui nous permet de nous rencontrer en
val était virtuelle dans un bureau
virtuel
les collaborateurs sont équipés d'un
casque de réalité virtuelle
chacun chez soi ils sont en immersion
des échanges facilités et quasi
naturelle déjà on est plus fluide
qu'avec du zoo ou du skype parce qu'on
met pas la vidéo on n'aurait que le son
et des positions d'objets 3d
en termes d'usagés finalement c'est
devenu très naturel c'est ça qui est
quand même surprenant
on s'est dit on va le tester on sait pas
du tout ce que ça va donner et on s'est
retrouvé à retrouver mes mimiques de
chacun les tout ce qu'est gestuelle en
fait un peu spécifique à chaque personne
on voulait retrouver dedans développé
depuis le début du confinement cette
solution est utilisé uniquement pour
l'activité de sky one portal une phase
d'expérimentation avant peut-être de
l'aco
merci alizés on ne sait pas possible on
va déjà voir un petit peu l'intérêt donc
on va communiquer un petit peu sur le
réseau sur ce type d' usage et si
effectivement on sent qu'il ya une
demande
on sera ravi effectivement de proposer
quelque chose qui soit un peu plus
packagées que ce qui est aujourd'hui
pour l'instant à l'état de prototype
spécialisé dans les secteurs du
divertissement de l'événementiel et du
service aux industries cette start up
est impacté par cette crise plusieurs
mesures du gouvernement ont pu être
déclenchées
objectif avoir une visibilité sur le
maintien de la trésorerie d'ici à la fin
de l'année
pas de réalité virtuelle encore mais
l'assemblée départementale des yvelines
se réunira bien à distance vendredi
séance retransmise en vidéo sur la
chaîne youtube des yvelines seul élu
présent sur place le président de la
collectivité pierre bédier et les autres
conseillers seront connectés depuis leur
domicile
à l'ordre du jour des décisions
directement en lien avec la crise
sanitaire avec notamment un plan d' aide
d'urgence exceptionnelle est mais aussi
d'autres délibérations lancement de
projet de maison médicale financement de
conventions d'associations oeuvrant dans
le secteur de la précarité de
l'insertion séance du conseil
départemental
à suivre à partir de 10h30 à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'agglomération se mobilisent pour ces
commerçants il ya notamment cette carte
interactive dont nous vous avons déjà
parlé
elle incite à consommer local elle
permet de repérer est les commerces
encore ouverts les plus proches de chez
soi agriculteurs maraîchers qui peuvent
notamment un demandait y figurer
gratuitement
et puis ce groupe facebook également
moyen pour les professionnels de se
faire connaître auprès des habitants et
aussi de partager leurs initiatives et
bonnes pratiques écouter d'ailleurs ces
propos recueillis par nicolas landry
regardez encore les chiffres ce matin on
en est à 2700 membres en l'espace d'une
dizaine de jours
alors dans ce site on retrouve dans ce
groupe facebook on retrouve non
seulement des commerçants qui là encore
se sont accaparés cet outil pour y
mettre à l'honneur leurs nouveaux
horaires leurs prestations et ses lois
sa aperçu également c'est un outil clé
saint quentinois ont se sont accaparés
pour s'échanger des boues pillot si je
puis dire de recommander leur l'a vu
notamment de pâques de recommander le
broc faux kolatier indépendant etc
le sport et cette décision qui se
faisaient attendre du côté de la fff la
fédération française de football a
confirmé aujourd'hui l'arrêt définitif
de ces compétitions amateurs pour cette
saison en raison de la crise sanitaire
pas de saison blanche pour autant les
classements arrêté au 13 mars sont figés
il y aura donc des montées des descentes
pour les championnats de ligue et de
district seule une équipe sera relégué
par cool pour les championnats de
nationale 3 et de nationale 2 en
revanche les règles d'accession et de
relégation restent les mêmes
c'est une salle d' escalade créé en 2014
à montigny le bretonneux verticale art a
ouvert depuis une dizaine
d'établissements partout en france cette
société sponsorise aussi une équipe de
grimpeurs professionnels qui devait
prendre part aux jeux olympiques de
tokyo l'été prochain ils ont finalement
été remportée écoutez à ce propos comme
gauclin il est le directeur
communication et marketing de vertical
art il a été interrogé par nicolas
landry
une équipe de quatre athlètes de haut
niveau donc français et canadien du coup
par rapport à ça nous qu'il ya un
processus de sélection propres à leur
propre à l'organisation dieu de l'ifsc
donc la fédération international
d'escaladé par rapport à ça là il ya
fanny gibert qui était en phase de se
qualifier mais ça a été arrêté les
sélections ont été arrêtés au vu du
contexte actuel il ya notre athlète sean
mc call qui est qualifié mais du coup
qui en attente entre guillemets de la
date il est confiné chez lui au canada
donc il continue à s'entraîner à se
préparer pour les géo qui a priori sont
sont des cas les certitudes sont décalés
d'année prochaine pour le 2 à peut-être
du coup il ya une meilleure organisation
la plus totale sur un point de vue un
entraînement parce que du coup il ya
plus de structures qui sont disponibles
ils sont confinés chez eux tout
simplement donc il ya une adaptation de
leurs systèmes d'entraînement de leur
préparation il ya fanny gibert faut
gérer la frustration du du report encore
de cet événement pour ce dernier ticket
olympique donc il ya une pression qui
est encore créé encore accentuée
vis-à-vis de sa tâche qu'on ne sait pas
comment ça va se dérouler ni ou et
surtout quand donc on a deux il faut à
être juste et l'implication de son
entraînement chez elle avec très peu de
matériel est gérée gérait cet événement
et c'est attendent surtout
les athlètes vont pouvoir se réentraîner
dans les pôles france beaucoup plus que
dans les salles privées
au vu du contexte actuel et de la
liberté du nombre de personnes qui sera
tolérée dans les structures privées et
du coup ils vont devoir se rabattre à
100% dans le dans les pôles france
les sportifs engagés dans cette équipe
devait être présentée le 6 avril dernier
avertit qu alors
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cet événement
est reporté au mois de septembre
emmanuel macron l'annoncé dans son
discours du lundi 13 avril les
événements rassemblant du public ne
pourront se tenir au moins jusqu'à la mi
juillet à saint quentin en yvelines le
premier festival pulsations était prévue
à la fin du mois de septembre de cette
année mais le confinement a poussé les
équipes organisatrices a repoussé le
rendez vous d'un an qu'on sort mélanie
poker ans à de la rédaction de tv 78 tu
sais ce dont vous allez parler avec
votre invité est oui dit françoise des
salles del r bonjour bonsoir
alors l'annoncé du report du festival
peut surprendre puisqu'il était prévu en
septembre mais le confinement que nous
connaissons depuis deux mois de mars a
en effet impacter votre préparation tout
à fait mauvais l'organisation depuis le
mois de mars est devenu extrêmement
compliquée puisque évidemment plus on
s'approchait du festival plus les choses
devenaient urgente et il fallait être de
plus en plus réactifs les contacts
n'était plus réactif les programmateurs
étaient tous beaucoup plus intéressés et
on le comprend par les reports des
artistes de leur spectacle et c'est que
par une réservation sur notre festival
donc voilà on a beaucoup réfléchi
travaillé par visioconférence comme tout
le monde et nous avons opté pour une
décision stage nous at on dit voilà
mais pourquoi au nom supplémentaire
c'est pour mieux préparer la prochaine
édition à venir
alors voilà c'est ça c'était la question
était est-ce qu'on laisse qu'on le dit
faire ou est-ce qu'on leur porte et donc
on a décidé
le reporter de date à date puisqu'il est
reportée au 25 et 26 septembre 2021 de
façon à ce que les choses soient claires
c'est un festival qui veut être qui veut
se brise et donc sur une période qui
sera dédiée donc on veut rester sur ce
calendrier là et puis ce temps qui nous
nous donnons en fait va nous permettre
de construire des parties de
l'accompagnement qu'on n'avait pas eu le
temps de construire notamment un club
des partenaires puisque c'est quelque
chose qui nous tenait à coeur de
construire un club des partenaires avec
tous les partenaires qu'ils soient
institutionnels qu'ils soient privés
qu'ils soient associatifs artistique
voilà donc on va avoir le temps de
construire ce club des partenaires et de
faire des événements qui sont des
événements précurseur pourtant ce club
des partenaires il va quand même se
tenir un petit peu cette année en
septembre vous conservez un rendez vous
malgré tout alors voilà on va créer un
premier rendez vous donc le partenariat
de l'île de loisirs restent très
effectif nous avons tout de suite
rencontré toute l'équipe avec la
directrice l'île de loisirs et qui a été
très favorable au report qui est
également favorable à ce club des
partenaires à des rendez-vous et le
premier rendez-vous de ce club des
partenaires aura lieu le 27 septembre à
lille de loisirs mais il va consister en
quoi c'est que tous les partenaires se
rencontrent vous pouvez vous ici aussi
partagé par exemple le mans votre vision
exactement reuver on va on va créer
plusieurs rendez vous celui ci sera le
premier ce sont des temps de rencontres
et d échanges entre tous nos partenaires
qui viennent de milieux et de cadres
professionnels très différents donc la
dynamique que construit anima sauce va
pouvoir prendre là vraiment tout son
sens puisque cette année supplémentaire
qui nous est donnée va nous permettre de
développer sa guise et de ses liens ces
contacts qu'on voudrait on voudrait
développer
est ce que ça vous permet aussi de voir
peut-être plus grand avec plus de rendez
vous plus d'animations vous vous gardez
le
que vous aviez déterminée pour cette
année alors le festival pulsations est
déjà très ambitieux donc les artistes
que nous avions déjà réservé entre
guillemets nous suivent tous donc c'est
très bien
les structures artistiques onirique
c'est la même chose nous suivent
donc voilà on a déjà un festival
extrêmement ambitieux dans nos dans nos
tiroirs donc il n'est pas vraiment prévu
qu'on soit plus ambitieux par contre ce
qu'on voudrait développer ces voilà tout
toute cette tous ces liens tous ces
échanges
vraiment ce soit le grand événement
fédérateur
voilà et j'en profite pour remercier
toutes ces personnes qui depuis le début
bénévoles institutions travaillent avec
nous qu'ils ont très bien accueilli le
festival et qui continue de poursuivre
cette démarche avec mercy françoise de
saldé l'air donc la première édition du
festival pulsations aura lieu les 25 et
26 septembre 2021 et merci à vous
également mélanie pour refermer cette
édition forcément d'autres rendez vous
de l'été sont remises en question le
moins molière par exemple est annulé à
versailles cet événement tourné vers le
théâtre la musique et la danse devait se
tenir au mois de juin
impossible donc de le maintenir pour la
mairie qui a confirmé l'information hier
mercredi environ 350 représentations
sont habituellement proposés dans les
parcs rues cartier salle emblématique de
la ville et versailles donne rendez-vous
en 2021
et puis la fête des loges aussi n'aura
probablement pas lieu cette année à
saint germain en laye c'est le maire de
la commune
arnaud péricard qu'il a annoncé l à 380
6e édition doit se tenir du 26 juin au
16 août
chaque année ce sont environ 200
attractions et manèges qui débarque en
forêt de saint germain en laye avec 3
millions de visites en moyenne chaque
année c'est le plus gros événement de la
ville et l'or est plus important en
région ile de france
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale merci de votre fidélité restez
chez vous bien sûr et très belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]